James Cleveland foreign secretary here
with us for immediate reaction to that
so pensions and benefits going up by at
least 10 percent
well we've seen those inflation figures
obviously the chancellor is going to be
making a statement to the house in just
over a week's time the decisions that he
and the treasury team will be making
will be very much informed by those
figures but boring though that is okay
you know that I'm not going to be
pre-announcing any of the measures that
might come in that statement on the 31st
but you promised as a government you
promised in your Manifesto well look we
do take Manifesto commitments incredibly
seriously as you know
um and uh and those figures of course
are concerning but they are similar to
in fact in some instances significantly
lower than inflation figures we're
seeing in many other parts of the
developed world as I say the the chance
and his team will be using those figures
to do their thinking and will be coming
up with a full packet of measures the
full details all the things that your
viewers will want to know about in just
over a week's time and that's when the
the announcements on the these on other
things will be put in the public domain
yeah but it was a Manifesto A promise
that you would increase benefits and
pensions in line with inflation yeah and
as I say we take Manifesto commitments
seriously but what I'm not going to do
what I'm not going to do is pre-announce
uh budget measures these figures will be
uh taken into consideration by the
chancellor and the team and as I say in
a little over a week's time they'll be
making a statement of the house for the
full range of financial measures okay
um
45p down to 40p back up to 45p 19p up to
20p
um corporation tax
um going up to 25 percent uh public
spending issues there energy price
guarantee that's been changed as well
what's the point of listros well what
we've got to remember is that we are
facing an unprecedented set of
circumstances but the Prime Minister was
absolutely clear and I think when I came
on the show last time I said she's
absolutely clear that what we ultimately
have to do is grow the economy and she's
still very much committed to that she
said that she wanted to protect families
and businesses that were facing
potentially huge uh energy price
increases this winter and she's done
that those were the main measures from
that but she's also said that she uh we
made mistakes she's sought to address
those uh Jeremy's now come in as
Chancellor he has made changes to make
sure that we can reassure the
international financial markets on which
we like every other developed economy
relies quite heavily for public
borrowing and we've seen that we've seen
that now have a positive effect there is
still tough times ahead there's no doubt
about that there is going to be a tough
winter for us and countries as I say
developed con economies all economies
frankly around the world and that's what
we're focusing on to protect the people
that need protection
and to get the economy going this is
only three weeks ago I mean this is not
a U-turn this is a 10 car pile up in the
fog that's your words not mine yeah it
is I would tell me why it isn't well as
I say these are circumstances which are
affecting countries right across the
globe interest rates interest rates are
already interest rates are already much
higher than we see here in the UK and
other parts of the world inflation is
higher in in many other parts of the
world this is really really tough
economic headwinds But ultimately the
prime minister is still committed to
grow the economy that's what the medium
term financial plan uh ultimately will
be uh designed to do but we've got to
recognize that the measures that we put
forward initially clearly were felt to
go too far too fast the Prime Minister
has uh has said that she's apologized
for the impact that that had on the
financial markets and the chancellor and
her are now working to continue with
that growth agenda to continue to
protect the people that need protecting
both from the economic situation here in
the UK and
ukrainians which is what I'm focused on
you know we see you know drone attacks
in Ukraine
so that's what we're focused on how many
more mistakes can she afford to make I
spoke to the Armed Forces Minister
yesterday uh James TP he said no more
mistakes
well no one wants to make mistakes but
I'll ask you how many more could you
afford to make So the plan is not to
make mistakes you don't say well you
know I've got a certain number of
mistakes that I'm allowed to make we we
don't aim to make mistakes and and
actually the the the simple truth in
life in in politics in business in life
is that mistakes happen they do happen
what you've got to do is recognize when
they've happened and have you humility
to uh to to make changes when you see
things didn't go right it was clear that
the uh a number of the announcements
some of the announcements but not all
some of the announcements in the uh the
statement that quasi made as Chancellor
had a negative effect on markets and
we've sought to address those things so
that we can focus on as I say growing
the economy protecting people from those
Rising bills helping ukrainians protect
themselves totally ripped ripped to
shreds the plan and Jeremy Hunt has come
up with something that even uh Rishi
sunak hadn't gone that far when it came
to his Economic Policy
um Ben Wallace said that he would resign
if defense spending uh was cut what
would you resign over I'm not I'm not
I'm not discussing uh resigning because
I've got too much work to do so I I have
got to ensure that the global events are
as far as we can uh as far as we can do
those global events are addressed so
that's why I'm that's why I'm very
focused on helping ukrainians defend
themselves because Russia's attack on
Ukraine has had a huge impact on global
Energy prices
on the foreign
secretary this is literally my job to
focus on China and Ukraine and Global
food prices Global Energy prices and
counter-terrorism and War around the
world that is literally my job 55 think
that she should resign well we've we've
we've we've gone through quite recently
a situation where lots of people were
saying oh Boris has got to resign Boris
has got to resign and at the time I said
okay you might not be happy but what's
your plan for for what happens next and
for those people what's happening for
those people who defenestrated uh Boris
they didn't have a plan for what's
happening next they're now criticizing
the new prime minister many of the same
people criticizing the new prime
minister and I just say again look
what we need at this point is we need to
get focused on delivery delivering those
minimum service agreements so
communities can get to work delivering
the infrastructure so that we can grow
the economy deliver calm confidence to
the markets and I don't think any of
those things would be served by you
wouldn't be fine I mean if if this is
the case I mean you'll be lucky to hold
on to your position more of more of the
people who actually voted for her now I
said that they would vote for Rishi
sunak well the the point I'm making is
that we have got to deliver when people
see governments deliver
numbers like this uh reduce and that's
what the Prime Minister said he said she
is focused on doing delivering the
infrastructure that unlocks economic
growth delivering our ongoing support
for Ukraine so that the the effects
which we're now feeling of inflation
um of of uh you know energy price Rises
and in many parts of the world food
insecurity these things can be addressed
that's what I'm working on that's what
the Prime Minister will be thinking
about as well as the domestic agenda as
well yeah I know but you have to have
faith in your prime minister in order to
have the respect not only in the UK but
also around the world I mean she's pmqs
it's only the third one she's done and
last week she said no spending cuts
um at all that's she laughed when um it
was put to a by kirst armor we now know
it could be 15 across the board
well as I say the Chance is going to be
setting out his plan next week and I'm
not going to speculate uh you've already
asked me about that but the the you know
the people who are criticizing the Prime
Minister and I and I get why people are
frustrated you know we look at poll
numbers of course it's disconcerting if
you're a member of the government but my
contention is the best way of addressing
those poll numbers is to demonstrate to
the British people that we are focused
on their priorities and we're delivering
on their behalf and if we do that those
numbers will head in the right direction
instead of the wrong direction what I'm
not convinced by far far from convinced
by is that going through another
leadership campaign defenestrating
another prime minister will either
convince the British people that we're
thinking about them rather than
ourselves or convince the markets to
stay calm and uh and and ensure things
like those uh bond yields and guilt
yields start coming back down
um and you know being angry I get I
totally get it but that's an emotional
response it's not a plan and the prime
minister's got a plan
we got a prime minister and as I say for
all the reasons I've just discussed I
don't think it's a good idea to be
focused on our you know internal
frustrations and I get why people are
frustrated but rather than focusing on
our internal frustrations what we what
we should be focusing on is delivering
for them why should we believe this plan
when the last plan was rubbish
that okay the the the Prime Minister and
the chancellor have have learned lessons
from what happened previously as I said
when mistakes happen
the right thing to do is learn from them
adjust and then move forward and that's
exactly what we're doing we've got the
Ukrainian Ambassador on the program
later on um he is obviously very
concerned uh about the power stations
that are being taken out by these
airstrikes what sort of air cover are we
going to offer to them well um I uh I
spoke with my opposite a number of the
Ukrainian foreign minister yesterday who
was saying about how drones were flying
over the area that he lived
um obviously the the attacks from the
air both through missiles and drones I
think are well I know is because Russia
has failed to gain ground in the land
War it's a it's a Vicious Kind of
reprisal attack we've already supplied
uh amram uh um air-to-air missiles to
help shoot down the uh the cruise
missiles that Russia have been using uh
we are we have imposed sanctions and
we'll look at sanctioning enforcement to
make sure the people selling Russia
things like those drones uh are
prevented from doing so so we close off
the supply five of those kind of
Munitions and also what we'll be doing
and I'll be speaking with my Ukrainian
counterparts just as the front of the
defense secretary is speaking with is
American counterparts about what more we
can do to help ukrainians protect
themselves from these these vicious
attacks from the air yeah it was with
some concern that we learned that Ben
Wallace went to Washington for these
urgent talks and when we did some more
digging here at Sky News apparently
there's concern that Putin could be
planning a nuclear attack and that's why
Ben Wallace went to Washington to
discuss it is that the case no so so we
speak to our European counterparts on
American counterparts or Ukrainian
counterparts regularly understood and
and we do so because we've seen a shift
in tactics from Russia that they're
moving towards uh more attacks on
civilian infrastructure rather than on
Military targets so these conversations
are a are a normal and regular part of
what is frankly a very abnormal and
perverse situation had to get on a plane
to do that do you he's got a nobody
urgently no no we do we there was
nothing urgent about it so the reason we
well there's urgency because of course
there's urgency because because
civilians are being targeted in a new
way and so we have to respond to that
and our response has got to be done at
PACE and there are conversations which
frankly you don't want to have
um uh over the over the telephone but we
speak face to face with our counterparts
pretty regularly it's part of what you
know Ben and I
um and indeed the Prime Minister and
others are doing to help keep us all
safe help the ukrainians defend
themselves against Russian attacks are
you brushing aside my question about
nuclear concern well what we do is we
discuss a full range of how we help the
ukrainians to defend themselves so I'm
not at the meeting I'm here rather than
over in the states so I don't you know
I'm I'm not going to guess or speculate
as to exactly the things that are
discussed but the point is that just all
the time
yeah I know I get that I get that but
the point I'm making is that we talk
about a range of issues every time we
speak
um what we are what we are seeing in
Ukraine is is brutality on a scale that
we are not used to uh in in Europe we
are seeing Putin uh put these vicious
attacks on civilian infrastructure so of
course we want to discuss uh how we help
the ukrainians about what might happen
in the future and as I say what I don't
want you to do is is focus on one
element of what would be what would be a
normal discussion from defense minutes
okay I I got a message from one of your
colleagues last night who said he he
went because
um the madman's got new because this is
how it was put
well as I say we would inevitably
discuss a full range of stuff but
ultimately this is a normal part of how
close friends like the US and the UK
work to support a really good friend
like Ukraine what are we going to do
with China seeing people
um who are peacefully protesting getting
beaten up yeah look that was
unacceptable that was unacceptable so I
had the Chinese charged Affair the the
number two in the Chinese Embassy uh
called into the foreign office summonsed
to the foreign office address yes I did
and did you speak to him no I didn't
that was done by one of my officials
um what did you say well we said this is
absolutely unacceptable that the uh the
protests were were peaceful and legal
they were on British soil and it is
absolutely unacceptable for this kind of
behavior now the my understanding is the
greater Manchester police will be
conducting a an investigation into this
and when I see the details of that
investigation I'll then decide what more
we might need to do on that so there
could be more to be done well as I say I
will see what the greater Manchester
it's outrageous that it's unacceptable
it is unacceptable okay I'll have to let
you go it's great to see you as always
thank you very much